[Music]
so
[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning we already know that time is
fast running out for countries including
the uk us and other allied forces to
evacuate people from afghanistan the
deadline of course next tuesday but now
there's another peril a warning of a
very high risk of a terrorist attack at
kabul airport it comes from an affiliate
of islamic state rivals the taliban
we'll be discussing this with the armed
forces minister james hippie and
labour's stephen kinnick also ahead on
the programme the final big festivals of
the summer are taking place across the
country this weekend i'll be speaking to
the lead singer of bombay bicycle club
as they prepare for the main stage at
all points east also on the show
i've never said it before
while you were falling in love
i was already there
i was already very much looking forward
to this one i will be speaking with
music legend jonah armatrader she's
honored for her work at this year's
independent music awards it is thursday
the 26th of august
on alert a warning of a very high threat
of terrorist attack at kabul airport the
uk and the us tell their citizens to
stay away
we're operating in a hostile environment
in a city and country now controlled by
the taliban
with the very real possibility of an
isis k attack
well despite that warning the rescue
operation to airlift afghans and other
nationals from kabul is continuing as
the taliban deadline draws near
migrants across the med a special report
as we track the thousands trying to
reach europe from tunisia
no jab no job care homeowners say rules
forcing staff to have the covert vaccine
could soon cause a staffing crisis
another medal for team gb at the
paralympics alien mcglynn and partner
helen scott winning silver in the
women's class b one thousand meter time
trial
and we're live here in northampton as
family and friends of maisie summers
newton wait nervously as she goes for
gold in tokyo
and it's looking fine and dry once again
across many parts of the uk and ireland
a little cloudier for some and warm in
the west i'll have the details for you
later
[Music]
morning all britain the united states
and australia have issued a warning to
their nationals to stay away from kabul
airport due to fears of an imminent
terrorist attack
officials in washington have been
somewhat more specific saying two of the
main gates at the terminal should be
avoided the attack threat comes from an
islamic state affiliate and piles more
pressure on the evacuation effort which
has been carried out of course under the
watchful eye of the taliban our foreign
affairs editor deborah haynes has our
first report
for those desperate to flee afghanistan
a new danger
the uk has issued a warning to stay away
from kabul airport
because of an ongoing and high threat of
a terrorist attack
but will anyone listen given this is the
hub of a massive evacuation effort
that's only got days left to run the
united states also worried
islamic state the key concern
it's hard to overstate the complexity
and the danger of this effort
we're operating in a hostile environment
in a city and country now controlled by
the taliban
with the very real possibility of an
isis k attack
we're taking every precaution
but this is very high risk
islamic state coruscant or isis k
emerged in around 2015 as part of an
expansion of the group's reach from iraq
and syria
the khorasan region historically covers
afghanistan pakistan central asia and
parts of iran
isis k fighters are thought to number up
to
2200 though this figure could well be
rising given the security vacuum left by
departing foreign troops they're mainly
based in kunar and nangarhar provinces
and are responsible for some of the
worst attacks in afghanistan one at a
maternity hospital in kabul last year
killed 24 people including mothers and
newborns
the groups led by a militant called
shahab al-muhajir previous leaders have
been killed or captured by u.s and
afghan forces
islamic state also no friend of the
taliban and how taliban leaders
negotiated with the u.s in their return
to power
they might try to do something to
disrupt
the agreements that have been struck and
you know launching an attack on kabul
airport now as this evacuation was
taking place would be a very good way of
causing some trouble
for the taliban and the west and
potentially causing everything to
unravel
despite the danger british and u.s
troops still push on with evacuation
flights
time running out to rescue the thousands
who need to leave
before these troops have to get out too
the final moments perhaps the most
perilous
debra haines sky news
well let's head to well the other end of
that journey for many people aisha's
ahead joining us from raf bryce norton
with the latest plane carrying evacuees
touchdown at just after midnight morning
aisha just bring us up to date with the
latest do we know much about who was on
board how many and so on
yeah well it's likely it was british
nationals and afghans on that flight it
landed here at rf bryce norton in the
early hours of this morning and it was
an raf voyager carrying around 250
people in total now this airlift
operation began nearly two weeks ago now
and in that time the ministry of defense
has confirmed that around 11 and a half
thousand people have been airlifted to
the uk and that includes british
nationals embassy staff evacuees from
allied countries as well as afghans
eligible for the resettlement program
having previously worked with uk forces
around 7 000 afghans have been evacuated
by the uk and that includes individuals
and their families as well
now currently around 2000 people are
being taken out of afghanistan every
single day but the pressure's really
ramped up especially overgrown concerns
that there is a high threat of a terror
attack occurring at kabul airport uk
officials have asked british nationals
to remain safe stay away from the
airport while they wait for their
evacuation flights and ben wallace said
that afghans eligible for the
resettlement program should try the
border to flee from afghanistan rather
than waiting for these flights so as
that deadline date of the 31st of august
looms the race is on to get as many
people back as possible safely as well
as the british troops
aisha many thanks indeed
uh we're joining us now on the programme
the shadow minister for asia at labour's
stephen kinnick mr kinnick very good
morning to you good to have you on the
show um i wonder if we can start with
the security situation in and around
kabul airport at the moment it does feel
like we are moving into the final stages
of british presence on the ground in
afghanistan how concerned should we be
about the prospect of an islamic state
attack
well any possible threat has to be taken
very seriously indeed and there are
clearly credible threats on the ground
and i do hope that people will follow
the advice
that's been given
we should also just pay a debt of thanks
to the brave soldiers and diplomats and
civil servants
who have done so much heroically trying
to move mountains there awful scenes uh
that we've seen on the television of
people wading through sewage
to try to get out um
and
babies being handed over razor wire by
mothers it is utterly heartbreaking and
although those brave diplomats and civil
servants and soldiers are doing so much
they've been badly let down by their
political masters
who've had 18 months to plan for this
and have completely failed to make the
necessary preparations to have an
orderly withdrawal so
serious questions do need to be asked
once we've got through this phase of of
getting as many people out as we can and
we understand that up to 2000 uh
interpreters and others who've helped
our armed forces could be left behind it
is utterly unforgivable
you described the situation as
heartbreaking and certainly with with
making no political judgments about
things i think everyone would certainly
agree with you
on that i do wonder though your thoughts
um about the situation that i'm i'm sure
you're aware of penn farthing uh
currently finds himself in i'm just
going to show our viewers a tweet that
he is uh recently released now i'll read
it to you so you can follow along uh
dear sir
uh he writes to in his in essence a
taliban spokesman he includes in the
tweet my team and my animals are stuck
at airport circle we have a flight
waiting can you please facilitate safe
passage into the airport for our convoy
um
what should if anything and the british
troops who are on the ground do he is a
british citizen we know where he is we
assume that british troops have been
outside the war on a few occasions
already at the airport your thoughts on
that
well
we had a call with uh mps had a call
with the defense secretary yesterday uh
ben wallis and he said we should not be
putting pets before people and i have to
say i agree with every word of that
statement
um i think mr farthing had the
opportunity as a british citizen to
leave last week on a plane
and i think what's always been clear is
that
this issue with this convoy that he has
now with pets dogs etc uh if it's
blocking the runway that so in a way
that's
not allowing human beings
to
escape uh from afghanistan then
that is problematic and i i think it
would be very useful to know how some of
these decisions are being made because i
think first of all the defense secretary
said he wouldn't be facilitating this
and now it is being facilitated so what
has changed in government to change that
position
you know mr farthing is doing
what he's doing because he feels
passionately and strongly about it we
understand that but we cannot be in a
situation where
we're potentially putting pets before
people
um speaking more generally though about
the future of afghanistan clearly
a huge amount of concern about hunger
and famine the withholding of aids
particularly as we edge closer to winter
will exacerbate that situation at what
point do we have to simply say look you
know the humanitarian
aspect of the situation on the ground in
afghanistan is the priority rather than
holding the taliban to promises which
sounded pretty empty when they made them
frankly
well i think those two things are linked
uh we need to exert leverage on the
taliban some of that leverage i think
can come through the the money that is
currently held the afghan government
reserves that are held in bank accounts
around the world but particularly in the
united states and are currently frozen
um in return for the the taliban uh
facilitating uh safe passage for people
who are uh trying to get out trying to
get to the refugee camps that will now
form on the borders with the
neighbouring countries
we can potentially use some of that
leverage that we have with with the
money that can be released so the
humanitarian crisis that we're facing
has to be dealt with with smart
diplomacy smart negotiations and some
real leadership and the united kingdom
needs to step up and start showing some
of that leadership rather than the
indecision and complacency that has been
the hallmark of this government right
from the beginning of this crisis
um mr kenneck i want to take us in a
slightly different direction it has been
some time since we've discussed internal
labour party politics but i do need to
get your thoughts on on the election of
the new head of the united union sharon
graham i mean she was
elected on a manifesto that in essence
said you know we have tried our
political project within labour it has
failed i mean how does the labour party
move forward with the united union
well my understanding is that uh
kyostama will soon be speaking with
sharon graham and has already
congratulated her on winning
the labour party and the trade union
movement
has to work closely together because
we were founded as a party in order to
further the interests of working people
and the trade union movement shares that
aim so it's absolutely clear that we
have to work together constructively i
am absolutely sure that that sharon
graham and kierstama and unite and the
labour party will be able to build a
stronger and more constructive
relationship and
we certainly really do look forward to
seeing that kicking off really at our
party conference
next month so i see it as a good
opportunity to turn the page and move
forward
and that can only be good news both for
the labour party and for the trade union
movement and for working people across
the country
stephen kinnick good to have you on the
show this morning thanks for joining us
thank you
uh let's bring our political
correspondent to monaco morning tomorrow
um
if we can maybe a little bit later we'll
do with again the internal labour party
politics but let's focus on the
situation in afghanistan penn farthing
is as we understand it trapped very
close to the airport we were discussing
this earlier i mean this was the
situation that ben wallace was warning
about wasn't it that's right and as we
enter into what is the final stretch of
this airlift we simply don't know how
much time is left but not much time ben
wallace the defense secretary said on
our programme we mustn't put pets before
people the former royal marine is trying
to take out dozens of the staff who work
at his animal charity who he says are at
risk due to their association with him
and a large number of animals who he
says
he can't be looked after in afghanistan
and people have crowdfunded to have not
an raf plane but a chartered plane to
take them out the concern was that if
they couldn't get to the airport because
of those taliban checkpoints the plane
might be blocking a runway
and they couldn't get to it anyway now
this seems this situation seemed to have
come to pass with mr farthing now saying
the plane is there and he can't access
it but questions for the defense
secretary because after he said this
would happen he then changed his mind
yesterday and said that the plane could
come in with some accusations um
including from mr farving's
friends in london that the prime
minister and his wife may have
intervened personally that has been
denied by number 10 but certainly
stephen kinnick there for labour saying
we need to know more about the
decision-making process
i'm told we do have time to talk about
labour party politics shannon graham the
unite union of course big financial
backer of the labour party
you get the feeling uh that the new head
of the union is willing to leverage that
money
you know to get a little bit of
political advantage within the party
that's right this was a surprise um
winning of the race by sharon gray and
this is to succeed len mccluskey unite
of course the biggest financial donor to
labour gives them millions of pounds
every year mr mccluskey became known as
a big supporter of jeremy corbyn and
someone very willing to express his
vocal opinions about the leadership of
the labour party under a number of
different leaders now she's won the race
she'd said a lot about how she wanted to
focus on bread and butter issues and not
internal labour party politics but
certainly and there's always going to be
a bit of leverage there since they give
them millions of pounds every year and
she's already expressed some opinions
about about kierstama's leadership and
we'll see how much more there is to come
on that or indeed whether mr stammer
uses his party conference um to say
anything about the party's ties with
unite as i know that some in the party
are urging him to do
tomorrow thanks very much indeed
uh no uh of course at doha uh that is
doha and qatar many flights from kabul
are passing through that part of the
world our correspondent
uh sally lockwood uh joining us from
doha today ah there we are sally i'm
just just as always just bring us up to
date with the latest the americans and
the british very clearly want to
maintain the tempo
of the evacuation process
yeah and boy hasn't that tempo stepped
up in recent days 19 000 people
evacuated by the americans in the last
24 hours
2 000 by the british now doha as i've
said in recent days is is a huge hub for
some of those evacuations because the
qataris are bringing in um plane loads
of afghan refugees but so are the
americans who have a huge base uh here
aloud based with up to 10 000 troops
based here at any one time and they've
been using this as one of their main
hubs for bringing in these evacuation
flights but with that comes huge
problems that chaos that we've seen at
cardboard airport with thousands of
people they're desperately struggling to
get on a flight well some of that chaos
has simply been exported in the number
of people that they've been bringing
here in
recent days now we went to see the
qatari side of uh alidade air base where
they've been bringing in their
evacuation flights we haven't seen
the american side yet we haven't been
allowed access but we've been hearing
reports that there is absolute chaos
there hangars
full of evacuated afghan people who are
sleeping on the floor there's one
bathroom between thousands of them there
are huge queues for six to eight hours
of evacuated passengers waiting just to
get into those hangars and the
processing is taking a long long time
and one of those issues is because
they're also having to check people for
security clearance reasons as well and
i've heard from qatari officials here
that that is one of the big hold-ups in
terms of processing all of these people
now qatar is doing what it can to try
and help
they currently have more than 6 000
people here in transit as well as uh
refugees that they're taking in
themselves many female students and
journalists have been
brought here by the qataris and they'll
be re-homed here they
do have thankfully a lot of
accommodation that's been built for the
world cup and that has been opened early
to help house
these refugees i should say one last
thing that i'm hearing on the ground
from kabul this morning that such is the
chaos unfolding there still with people
still trying to get to the airport not
able to get to the airport but with that
has come other problems i've heard from
someone this morning in kabul who said
that there are aid workers on the ground
at the airport now trying to round up
unaccompanied minors children who've
been left behind or got lost in all the
chaos trying to work out who they are
and where they need to be so many many
problems unfolding on many different
levels here
sally thanks very much indeed i will
continue to monitor the situation in and
around the airport as of course you'd
expect um but still to come on the
program this morning at 25 to 8 i'll be
speaking to one of the british army
interpreters waiting and hoping to be
flown out of afghanistan
i will be asking the armed forces
minister james hippie how that
evacuation effort is progressing he
joins us at temper state
and at half past eight wish you weren't
here we'll ask the head of tourism for
cornwall or i'd rather holidaymakers
stayed away
[Music]
well as part of our special series on
migrants sky news has been investigating
the huge numbers of people attempting to
cross from north africa to europe well
the number who've died trying to cross
the mediterranean has nearly doubled
this year according to the international
organization for migration now let's
take a closer look shall we at least
1146 people died attempting to reach
europe by sea
in the first six months of 2021.
513 migrants are known to have died in
the same period last year
the central mediterranean route from
libya and tunisia to italy was the
deadliest claiming
741 lives
the italian islands of lampedusa has
seen a huge influx in migrants
back in may more than 2 000 of them
landed in just 24 hours pushing the tiny
island to its limit with one official
describing the situation there as
literally explosive
250 people are known to have died trying
to cross the atlantic ocean between west
africa and the canary islands
the western mediterranean route between
north africa mainly morocco and algeria
to spain so at least 149 lose their
lives
and a minimum a minimum of six people
dies on the eastern mediterranean route
from as you can see at turkey uh to
syria turkey and syria to greece uh but
the international organization for
migration warned that the number of dead
may be severely underestimated given
multiple social media posts of families
looking for loved ones and reports of
possible invisible shipwrecks skies
europe correspondent adam parsons has
the support
dawn breaks on the fishing waters of
lampadusa and with it
a distant outline
it's a small boat packed with people
the italian border police have seen the
boat and are on their way
on board there are 12 migrants young men
who wave and offer victory salutes
they've come from tunisia
the police follow their boat and they
send over a couple of officers in a
rigid inflatable to guide the migrants
towards the port
and this is why lampedusa is so
important in the story of migration
those people have traveled in that boat
from tunisia about 80 miles away and
when they land on this island they'll be
in the european union
the migrants arrive in harbour they're
kept on board for a while details are
taken
but eventually
they step off
they're given medical tests and then
taken away in vans
and this is where they go
an overcrowded detention center
that looks a lot like a prison
sangare had arrived the previous night
she told us she'd escaped abuse in ivory
coast and had come here on a packed boat
from tunisia
[Music]
[Music]
the dark is often used as cover
smugglers can transfer migrants from
large ships onto much smaller boats
making them harder to spot
on the night we went out police and
coast guard were looking for seven
different vessels they do pursue
smugglers but mostly their job is about
search and rescue
and it is relentless
the morning brings more evidence of
migrant arrivals
the waters around lampadusa are dotted
with these abandoned vessels
littered with
food and rubbish
the skipper of our boat removes fuel
from them as a safety measure
this the debris left by desperate people
making dangerous journeys
and those voyages start here on the
tunisian coast itself a seascape of
discarded wrecks
this whole area is a center for the
lucrative business of people smuggling
migrants come here to offer cash they
often can't afford in return for the
chance of getting to europe
the money goes to people like ali he's
26 a people smuggler wanted for
trafficking migrants across the water
from tunisia to lampedusa he is
unapologetic and apparently unafraid
a dangerous combination
andy's
motion
be
it's a whole industry and at the heart
of it are the middlemen
this man claims he is careful but that
others are simply greedy and callous
[Music]
[Music]
and people do die in vast numbers bodies
wash up along the tunisian coastline
nameless and often forgotten
this dusty strip of land is now a
cemetery for migrants who didn't survive
the journey
um
foreign
more than a thousand people have already
died this year trying to navigate this
particular sea crossing
but still they come
back in lampedusa there are more rusting
reminders
this decrepit old trawler arrived
recently with nearly 500 crammed aboard
for those wanting a new life this island
has a magnetic attraction and the flow
of people
isn't going to stop
adam parsons sky news lampedusa
also this morning thousands of
firefighters have been brought in to
tackle a large wildfire threatening one
of california's most popular tourist
resorts the blaze is heading towards
lake tahoe and has already destroyed
hundreds of homes in san bernardino
county
music lovers at some of britain's
biggest festivals will be offered
coronavirus vaccines this weekend
organisers of the leeds and reading
festival say that ticket holders will be
able to get a jab as long as they aren't
too drunk
passengers on board a mexican military
helicopter and people on the ground had
an incredible escape after it
crash-landed a warning you may well find
these pictures
somewhat alarming uh well the helicopter
was trying to reach areas affected by
the recent hurricane grace when reports
say it suffered mechanical failure as
you can see well despite a mini bus
and a car being as you can just about
see directly underneath the helicopter
landed just clipping the edge of the bus
uh three people on board including a
senior local politician were said to be
taken to hospital suffering minor
injuries
very very lucky escape
well done to the pilot uh time to see
how the weather is looking as we nudge
towards the weekend nas is standing by
with the details how's it looking
well believe it or not for a bank
holiday weekend it's looking mostly fine
for many areas it's all thanks to high
pressure that is just not budging it's
staying around for the rest of this week
and well into next week too
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so high pressure sticking
around in fact it's not really budging
at all over the next few days and into
the new week as well it's going to
produce mostly fine and settle
conditions that doesn't mean we're going
to see wall-to-wall sunshine though
there will be some cloud here and there
at times in fact it's fairly cloudy out
there this morning missing murky out
towards parts of the west particularly
for northern ireland but most of the
clouds and the mist and the fog should
lift and clear and break up and we'll
see some good spells of sunshine this
afternoon the west will be best in terms
of the sunshine and the highest
temperatures especially across ireland
northern ireland western scotland it
will be somewhat cloudy around eastern
parts of england though breezy around
the east coast with one or two showers
too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nice thanks very much uh still to come
well in the next few minutes we'll
hopefully be hearing from one of the
british army interpreters hoping to be
flown out of afghanistan that's next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
obviously pulled up
out and they're being used as missiles
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
[Music]
and not only design but biology to
create new materials which actually are
fully sustainable and biodegradable
because of private there is a mass
increase of single-use plastics being
discarded so
for me it seemed like a great
opportunity to have a material which
didn't have a longevity of plastic but
could degrade back into the earth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back day two of the paralympics
and guess what more medals for great
britain uh let's speak now uh mark
jordan from tokyo in fact nbc sports
reporter at lewis johnson lewis great to
see you and your highlights of the day
so far what else do we have to look
forward to
lots of things neil welcome great to see
you i was here for the olympics and
great to be back in tokyo covering these
paralympics so it's day two of these
games and earlier today i was at men's
wheelchair basketball team usa the
defending gold medalist beat germany
58-55 the united states was down by six
at halftime but boy there was some hot
shooting in the second half from
american brian bell he led the team with
20 points off the bench to help them in
that win now the german women's
wheelchair basketball team was able to
win against australia they did so
beating them 77-58
and team gb took on japan that was just
a short time ago it was the host nation
winning 54-48 over the brits well
tonight we'll see more action from the
yoyogi national stadium for wheelchair
rugby a highly anticipated matchup
between great britain and new zealand
and tomorrow i'll be back at my home
olympic stadium for the start of track
and field 14 medal events to be
contested we'll also be watching the 36
year old american lex gillette who
returns for his fifth paralympics he's
competing as a t11 athlete which means
he's legally blind and gillette has won
four consecutive silver medals in the
long jump so lex is searching for his
very first paralympic gold on the track
we'll also see the man who's been
compared to the great usain bolt himself
brazil's petruccio ferrari dos santos
currently the world record holder in the
100 meters dos santos is hoping to
defend his olympic gold and finally
we'll see the 17-time paralympic
medalist tatiana mcfadden she's
something else of the united states and
she'll be competing for the first time
in the t-54 5000 meters so neil lots of
paralympic inspiration to come from
tokyo we're looking forward to it and we
hope that you all enjoy it there list
you know what i'm getting the impression
you might just be enjoying yourself just
a little bit out there in tokyo continue
to do so and we'll talk to you again
soon take care
new rules mean that from the autumn
anyone working in a care home will have
to be fully vaccinated against
coronavirus the bosses of some homes say
that could lead to staff shortages when
the restrictions are introduced in
november skies fraser mod has the detail
across england care home owners are
worried they could be facing a winter
staffing shortage caused by the
impending requirement for all their
workers to be vaccinated against
coronavirus the deadline is november the
11th and the government's own
predictions are that up to 40 000 of the
more than half a million care workers in
the country won't be fully vaccinated by
then and with the annual flu season on
the horizon the industry fares not only
for itself but for the nhs
there are people who are adamant they're
not going to be vaccinated and across
the care industry the the knock-on
effect of
making it mandatory
is could be horrific i think horrific is
a word to use
right at the start of flu season
winter illnesses hospitals are going to
will already be under pressure and
they'll have nowhere to discharge
their patients too so it's going to
cause bed blocking at the hospital to a
degree that we haven't seen before
another chair of trustees says the move
is grossly unfair and even borders on
blackmail
in wales scotland and ireland they don't
have to be vaccinated there is no
compulsion
and that seems even more unfair
well you know
why
if they work for the nhs they don't have
to be vaccinated
no one else in england
has to lose their job because they don't
want a vaccine
pj care employs 600 staff at three sites
providing specialist neurological care
for over 180 residents like darren he
thinks the government's approach is the
right one i think he should become
political i think so morally they should
want to take it anyway
because they're working with vulnerable
people
and
they'd be they could be affected
but not all the staff agree most are
fully vaccinated but even so they still
think that making that mandatory is a
heavy-handed approach
you know long-term i think it's ideal
that staff do have both vaccinations but
i also think you've got some you know
that it should be down to their personal
choice i think also there needs to be a
lot more research and
a lot more data available than what
there is at the moment for me personally
it's more religious reasons personal
reasons
i think people should have that choice
at the moment i think there's not enough
information available
the government says it has a
responsibility to do everything it can
to reduce the risk for the most
vulnerable and has introduced the
regulation following extensive public
consultation the fear remains though
that a sudden drop in care home staffing
at a difficult time of year could
increase pressure on the nhs by simply
shifting the risk rather than reducing
it
fraser moored sky news milton keynes
at least 20 people are reported to be
killed following flooding in venezuela
officials say heavy rain caused
mudslides
which destroyed more than a thousand
homes
uh one godfather of a japanese yakuza
crime gang has been sentenced to death
for conspiracy to murder it's the first
case of capital punishment being handed
out to a mob boss in the country reports
say that the 74 year olds told the trial
judge you will regret this for the rest
of your life
dentists are warning that people could
end up waiting nearly two years for
treatment research by the faculty of
dental surgeons suggests the backlog
caused by the lockdown could take more
than a year to clear
coming up after the break we'll be
hearing about the dangerous journey
taken by thousands of migrants as they
try to cross the mediterranean from
tunisia
[Music]
incredible you know it was all teamwork
obviously i swam as hard as i could but
yeah we knocked off we knocked off a lot
of time um brian thompson and scott
dawson planned plan the tides absolutely
meticulously um i can't pretend there
wasn't a lot of tidal assistance but um
yeah just an incredible swim and so so
pleased that we've managed to manage to
get it done successfully yeah so because
we're going for we were going for a
world record attempt i'm not allowed to
touch the kayak so um yeah it wasn't
allowed to do that we um we were passing
food and water attached by a bit of
string from the kayak um so that was
every 45 minutes i was topping up on
fuel keeping hydrated and and obviously
just so we can keep going but yeah we
didn't stop at all 15 hours and nine
minutes which was more than we could
have ever wished for we aimed for 17
hours was was mentioned and i thought to
be honest that was was um optimistic but
to get back in 15 hours you know two
o'clock in the morning loads of people
down there still at that time that all
come out to wish us you know say thanks
and
just the support was incredible well i
think it was about 18 degrees i was in a
wetsuit um it's not it's not too bad
it's not massively cold um obviously a
lot of skin swimmers will
we'll say that's incredibly warm um but
yeah we had spring tides it was very
choppy at times some of the tide races
there was a tide race of some cats which
was you're suddenly swimming in flat
water and all of a sudden you got
standing waves you know a good two three
feet high i almost took my goggles off
so we had some some hairy experiences
but i was pre-warned pre-armed and the
team were just incredible managed to get
around on scene it was just an
overwhelming success
so i'm very very passionate about trying
to protect our oceans plastic pollution
is a huge problem that we face you know
around the world and it's something we
can all make a difference about um it's
not you know there's a lot of things
that go on in this in this in this world
that we can't really do a lot about them
but plastic pollution
um we can all make a big difference we
can stop trying to use single-use
plastic um avoid it where possible and
you know get out there do beach cleans
raise awareness about it so yeah very
passionate about that there's three
three different charities we're raising
money for clean jurassic coast oceans to
earth and my mate frosty down in
cornwall turn the tide they're absolute
legends these guys and they're out all
the time actively on the beaches
cleaning up you know education as well
um frosty you need to vote to get to
some of the little codes and things um
to get in there and clean them out you
just can't get to without access from
the water so he's gonna get a vote the
other guys are going to put it towards
their continued efforts and it's just
going to make such a difference
[Music]
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
most places will see bright or sunny
spells this afternoon once any early
murky conditions clear and low cloud
breaks up it'll be a mainly dry day too
but a few light showers are possible in
the extreme east where it'll be cloudy
and breezy at times so taking a look at
the air pollution levels on a scale of 1
to 10 with 10 being very high most
places will continue with low levels of
1 to three with predominantly maritime
air persisting across the uk however
isolated moderate levels of air
pollution are possible over central
parts of scotland
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
as part of our special series on
migrants sky news has been investigating
the huge numbers of people attempting to
cross from north africa to europe this
morning we've seen pictures revealing
how thousands of people are regularly
attempting the journey from tunisia to
the italian island of lampedusa
joining us now in the programme regional
programme advisor for the danish refugee
council yad busani um yeah it's thanks
very much for joining us this morning
and and as i was just saying we know
from my colleague adam parsons reporting
that thousands of people continue to
make that
the attempt to cross to europe despite
the fact that tunisian graveyards are
increasingly being filled by people who
failed to make it across why are they
attempting to make this journey in your
mind
thank you i think it's despair to just
to name one one reason
um
these young people are trying to cross
to europe because they didn't find
the right opportunities in their home
countries in tunisia and
they try to to have a better life a
decent life and that's why they're
trying to
reach europe thinking
that they will have this better life
in terms of those who are attempting to
cross from tunisia can we generalize as
to as to their origin as to their
nationality i mean are the majority
tunisian for example that would seem
perhaps unlikely
yeah according to the last uh data and
stats from from unasian from our uh
mixed migration center which is uh which
has an institutional link to the danish
refugee council and is an independent
source of
data regarding a mixed migration uh
you know those the majority of those
people are tunisian the majority of
people reaching out uh reaching the
italian shows are tunisians
and there are also other nationalities
because departure from tunisian shows
from zazis from facts from idea from
others
include also other nationalities be it
like migrants who are
being in tunis and indonesia in general
or asylum seekers and refugees wouldn't
find the right protection in tunisia as
well
is there anything that officials that
the government in tunisia can can do to
the very least reduce
the flow of people going attempting the
crossing and therefore the debts i mean
we know how difficult it is you know in
this country you know the crossing of
crossing that is being made from cali uh
to the south coast of england it seems
impossible to police that so what hope
for the tunisian
authorities mean i can i can't just
mention what what happened a couple of
days ago i mean an arrest of one of the
smugglers who was behind uh several
attempts to cross uh illegally or
regularly to uh to europe uh tunisian
authorities are cooperating with uh with
uh the partners like italy the european
union and heirs uh to try to uh address
the root causes of this phenomenon of
this problem that is facing uh both
shows of the mediterranean but we cannot
rely only on a purely security approach
to this to this problem uh definitely
they are doing border patrols uh control
of the maritime borders there are a lot
of efforts in interception before these
attempts happen
there are a lot of risk you had seen by
the tunisian navy uh by uh
by many other actors but it's not enough
we have to uh look at the very uh root
causes of this phenomenon which is the
despair of these people they are not
only young people they are adults they
are women head of families
they are minors so it's not only because
of economic reasons it is mainly because
of that but there are other different
reasons and that needs a holistic
approach comprehensive approach where
authorities
of the hosting country where
international organization
organizations have a good solid
corporation to help these people
believe that they can have a decent life
in their home countries um yeah i wonder
your thoughts and the potential impact
and the taliban taker takeover of
afghanistan
may well have of course clearly much of
the international focus has been on
kabul international airport that is the
way that britain and others are getting
their nationals out but you go to the
borders and we are seeing huge queues
thousands of people desperately trying
to leave the country
yeah
definitely i am representing here at the
danish physique council in tunisia but i
would uh direct the dear viewers here
and and usaf neil to to uh the
statements of our uh secretary general
miss charlotte island
who was
very worried about what is happening in
afghanistan and who reassured everybody
that the danish refugee council is
staying in afghanistan we've been there
for 20 years we're going to stay there
and we're going to do everything
possible
in corporation close cooperation with
all different humanitarian actors to
help
those
vulnerable people in afghanistan i mean
it's clear that migration now is the
only lifeline for these vulnerable
people and that includes i mean to
protect them that includes safe passage
for these people a lot of cooperation
between uh
you know states and the region between
humanitarian organizations to to
to be able to mobilize the right
humanitarian aid to these people but
again uh we have we have a very strong
position regarding that uh regarding
this dire humanitarian situation in
afghanistan uh you add to that the
pandemic uh the drought uh you know the
ongoing conflict since 40 years it's too
much for these people um yeah
uh really appreciate you taking the time
uh yeah basically from the danish
refugee council there
it's time for us to check in and see how
the weather is looking now nasa's
standing by